the Desert Shores Community getting
ready to comply with the mandatory Turf
conversion but many residents are not in
favor of what they're hearing the
board's most effective option is costing
homeowners they are hundreds of dollars
and of course sparking a lot of
questions they want us to take it out
and put a low water Desert Landscaping
which actually makes it hotter Jean zai
has been living in Desert Shores since
2015 and isn't a fan of the community
association's Turf conversion plan what
they're proposing is they've only gotten
one bid for one phase last summer State
lawmakers enacted assembly Bill 356
which prohibits the use of the Colorado
River water to irrigate non-functional
Turf after January 2027. it's very
upsetting because as a family we do
enjoy the Lagoon we enjoy the grass the
trees and like we like nature I mean it
just it's a different element that we do
enjoy
according to the association's
newsletter the board has been working
with the Southern Nevada water authority
to determine exactly how much Turf will
be required to be removed
Zai sharing these images with 8 news now
from Wednesday night's Pac town hall
right now Desert Shore residents tell me
they pay about a hundred dollars a month
for landscaping services in addition to
that fee there would be a one-time
charge of sixteen hundred dollars for
single-family homes and eight hundred
dollars for those living in Condos for
the turf conversion they would have two
years to pay that amount still too much
money it's more than three times my car
payment you know it's a it's a cost of a
mortgage for people it's a home mortgage
payment
well we did reach out to the Desert
Shores Community Association about this
issue and we were told our request was
passed on to its lawyers and that
someone would respond well that hasn't
happened yet the next board meeting is
on July 27th